fan favorite Mobsters rising stars and
tragic icons on the biggest night in
Hollywood the Oscars and memorium
segment had some major snubs the Academy
Awards are designed to celebrate the
most outstanding work in entertainment
on top of saluting the best performances
and talent from a given year every
ceremony also features a moment of
reflection to honor the most notable
filmmakers who passed away that year the
95th edition of the Academy Awards
featured an emotional and memorium
segment set to a musical performance by
Grammy winner Lenny Kravitz and a
heartfelt introduction from John
Travolta the Montage highlighted a long
list of icons like Olivia Newton-John
James Khan Angela Lansbury Raquel Welch
Wolfgang Peterson and songwriter Bert
Bacharach along with many other industry
favorites but 2023s and memoriam also
made some blatant omissions there was no
mention of Saving Private Ryan star Tom
Sizemore who died at 61 and Hayes the
Donnie Brasco and volcano star who
enjoyed a lengthy career in both film
and television was also known were to be
seen she was 53 other Legends of their
craft Leslie Jordan Gilbert Gottfried
Cindy Williams Paul Sorvino Tony sirico
and Fred Ward were also seemingly
forgotten despite their notable
contributions to Hollywood over the
decades but one of the Academy's biggest
missteps involved leaving out a
performer who starred in a film that was
up for Awards in three categories in the
2023 ceremony despite the fact that
triangle of sadness was in contention
for Best Picture best director and best
original screenplay the ceremony failed
to acknowledge the death of actor
Charles B Dean she was just 32 and fans
of the star's portrayal of Yaya in the
film didn't miss a beat are you jealous
no no I don't know I don't know one
viewer tweeted she was just at the
beginning of her acting career and had
so much ahead of her I'm sad the Oscars
failed to honor her another wrote The
Academy not including Cheryl B Dean and
the tribute is disgusting rest in peace
Queen for some the Omission threw a wet
blanket on an otherwise enjoyable event
one fan wrote I'm still troubled by the
speech interruptions and the lack of
charl B Dean in the in memoriam but yeah
it was a solid ceremony it's those
moments when you wish you could just
press pause and take it in still Dean's
exclusion wasn't the only one to rub
social media users the wrong way
legendary actor Paul sorvino's career
began back in the 70s and lasted decades
until his death in 2022 at 83. he
appeared in many notable films including
Nixon cruising and Romeo and Juliet but
his performance as Paul Cicero in
Goodfellas is arguably his most
well-known and beloved role into
something I could do don't you think I
would do it you know me I would like to
help you out with a bottomless list of
credits to his name viewers were shocked
at the Academy snubbing someone who
devoted their life to serving the
industry so well one fan posted Paul
Sorvino not making the Oscars Memorial
segment is likely the biggest snub in
memoriam's segment history and yet
another asked what the heck did Paul
Sorvino do wrong for not being honored
in the Oscars in memoriam and some took
the academy to task directly with one
writing hey Oscars when you did the
immemorial tribute you forgot to include
Paul Sorvino Good Fellas hello just
after the ceremony any possible
explanations for these shocking snubs
remain a mystery but it's not as if the
academy isn't to blame show producers
can reportedly add entries to the in
memoriam segment right up until the
actual day of the ceremony with that
amount of last minute flexibility
there's seemingly no good reason why
Sorvino Dean and others couldn't have
been included well we may never know if
these icons and new stars of the
industry were intentionally left out one
thing's for sure we can never go back in
time and give them the honors they
deserved
[Music]